this is a production of cornell
university all right
welcome to the show how's everybody
doing uh jim
thanks for joining us we'll get to the
red sox and the yankees on their heels
in a minute uh i have a lot of red sox
fans i have to deal with but let's start
talking with
talking about a picture i got from carl
uh this week off of twitter
they're excavating the greens at pebble
beach
and you can see the layered profile
there from hundreds of
100 years of top dressing
superintendents making
holes the layered profiles the the
tines the deep tines that have happened
there over the years
an absolutely fascinating picture to
start out the week
which makes me think about those top
dressing and air fine
and hoping that you're measuring right
carl and i talk a lot about measuring
things uh this is a
usga's got a very simple handy dandy
method for using a little inca mat
and a a cooking tray a cookie tray
and collecting some of the sand and
seeing how it performs
um obviously we continue to have great
pictures of people
uh getting their family involved uh
doing all sorts of things
rakin uh and and even squeegee and
uh and working bunkers so uh very
exciting time for families to get out
there
and i thought really good here from
chris harriman uh running a member
golfer shop open house
improving communications with the people
you work with so that they understand
you know what's going on
obviously you want to serve them
alcoholic beverages and get them as
loopy as you can possibly get them
and then show them uh some of the things
that you need money for so you can
upgrade your equipment so carl let me uh
get to you here on the bmp tip
uh once again this is a project that
we've been working on with the rochester
institute of technology
the new york state pollution prevention
institute uh trying
to measure and improve adoption of the
bmps we've got a wonderful website that
you can go to and sign up many of you
might be receiving emails about this and
of course carl
we've got this lovely poster and for
those of you watching on
news channel 3 here the live version you
can see
uh carl's mug shot with the poster sir
carl without any further ado
what's the tip of the day yeah so you
know in our water section here we have a
tip
uh talking about stressing the turf um
and just allowing some drought stress
early in the year springtime and
and in the fall time is when we um
actually recommend this
the most because you're not gonna you're
not gonna lose any grass at these times
but the stress will help you going into
the summer you can
maybe promote some more root growth you
can promote the bent grass
a little bit more if you kind of have
one of those uh you know hodgepodge bent
poa systems
and if we get to the picture on the next
slide you'll see kind of that stress
that that we might be talking about
um you can see this little plot out here
on on our cornell golf course
uh last year just taking some pictures
over the course of the year and you can
see the
the bent grass on the left hand of the
on the left-hand side of this image you
can actually see some of the footprints
maybe getting close to work there but
the po are not liking it so much kind of
uh fading into its yellow
uh stress uh state there and these are
some of the things that over time
is going to make a big difference you
might not see the bent grass completely
take over that poe in one year
um but over time this sort of stressing
particularly again in the shoulders of
the seasons
uh helps out with if you want to promote
that bench press growth
and we actually you know on our poster
we have this little pro trip and this
comes from
rick slattery who's really been so
integral uh as a superintendent who's
gone through these things
you know he likens it to an athlete and
athletes you know they work out they
have to stress themselves and that
builds their muscle it builds their
speed
uh but they don't do that in the middle
of the season right a guy playing a
super bowl isn't gonna
you know put up some sets of 330 on a
bench press
the night before super bowl but he might
do that in in the in the pre-season or
or week one
um and this is kind of you know what
we're trying to liken it to in the
shoulders of the season so stress that
turf a little bit
that will help it be a little bit more
resilient uh moving into the summertime
excellent carl uh and of course uh you
know
uh jim will say but tom brady could
bench press 325 pounds before the super
bowl and be perfectly fine so
listen let me do a little quick uh check
of the weather uh what we got what we're
thinking
and then get right to the conversation
with jim lots lots of ground to cover uh
with the
really uh landmark publication that came
out at the end of last year so
we'll start out with temperature and and
if you've been paying attention at all
to the show the last several weeks
you know we were as many as three weeks
ahead
and even if you look out in in balmy
buffalo you see buffalo remains
uh close to three weeks ahead relative
to normal
uh considering this time of year most
everybody else
throughout the region is getting closer
and closer to normal
temperature conditions as we've hit a
bit of a stall and you look at the
outlook
for the next week and you can see
widespread
below normal expectations uh for much of
the northeast
and at the same time uh a lot of the
places that had some really dry
and even borderline drought conditions
have been
well above normal in rainfall in fact
most
are doing fairly well south jersey and
the delmarva you could start to see the
real break in the pattern
uh over the last week where it's wet
versus dry
and the prediction for the coming week
will be
cool and wet for the next couple of
weeks which of course will
you know extend the springtime slow
growth a little bit we're talking about
you know lows in the 30s and 40s and
highs only in the 50s and 60s here in
the northeast now
you know oddly enough you start to look
at the disease models and you see a
little bit of a tick
uh at least uh for a day or two here
with dollar spot but this is not the
kind of thing i think
you have to worry about because when you
look at the forecast website
you see that the next week really is not
indicating
a significant increase in stress for
dollar spot risk anyway
uh moving forward so so you know the
wrap up for the weather is soil
temperature
and again you can see the gradient here
where
it's pushing into the upper 60s low 70s
down in the delmarva south jersey the
delmarva peninsula and even into the
philly area
well into the 60s and of course 65 is is
where the summer patch sprays typically
go on
uh so many probably in the metro area
we'll be looking at that this week but
look closely monitor your soil
temperature this week
because we may not get much movement uh
with the cooler weather
uh forecasted now listen the topic of
discussion and if you're out on golf
courses in the northeast this time of
year jim you know from growing up man
it's
seed head heaven and of course it really
has been revolutionized in the last
couple of years
uh with sean askew's work looking at
these late season applications
uh for seed head suppression and we've
talked about this uh with uh you know
matt elmore and other folks
uh sean askew about the health benefits
of maybe reducing
uh the seed head stuff based on cooper's
work
from the 80s right and so now you're
starting to see
on putting greens where seed head
suppression you know wasn't performed
the
dense uh what i'm going to say to get
you
irked is the perennial population of
plants right
that start to you get some level of
flowering you can see
you know a lot of places will apply seed
head suppression across
all 18 greens and then invariably two or
three greens will still look like this
now
i can say this is we don't see as much
of this
where people use the fall applications
because even if you miss the spring
you're still probably getting between 60
and 70 percent
uh suppression moving forward so jim
here's the
conversation points for us right this is
the dense
high shoot density sort of oakmont pola
that you find
uh at least i get to see all the time at
bethpage black
where we've had a few of these greens
put in maybe some of the other
uh greens throughout the northeast with
benton poa
you start to see the real differences in
growth habits right you see the power
really surging the bent sort of coming
along
getting a little leggy you'll see guys
go out uh and vertical
in these things and you know no one's
afraid of sort of beating up
annual bluegrass in the spring based on
uh what turgeon proposed many years ago
as a
life cycle a seasonal life cycle i'm
sure you're gonna tell me this is
no longer uh valid and and it's because
uh back in
uh december um you had uh
finally accepted this publication on the
po annual life cycle and
essentially what it looks like you
basically said
is you're not sure if it's a perennial
that the environment
kills or it's an annual that maintains a
perennial cover and so i don't want to
explore that a little bit with you jim
about the big shift in thinking here you
know it still doesn't i mean
i don't even i want to talk a little bit
about the academic aspects of it
but i also want to talk about the
practical aspects of it as we
think about managing this species as
some people continue to choose it as the
grass of choice jim uh throughout the
throughout the northeast so
uh let me look at you and hope my
internet holds up
welcome to the show um
when is annual bluegrass not annual
bluegrass anymore
and it's something else i mean i i don't
know frank it's a complicated question
and you know i got to give credit to my
graduate student devin carroll she
has kind of devoted her dissertation to
this topic and
you know it says something about her
work ethic that goes over to the library
at the university
and says i want to track poe anua
through the
through the scientific literature from
linnaeus
forward so you know the first citation
in there is from the 1750s
when the species was first characterized
and what she learned in doing that and
that's what's detailed in that paper is
that
this has kind of been a case of the
telephone game that the narrative about
this plant over time
has kind of gone a little bit off the
rails you know
there the original botanical description
speaks about this as an
annual but doesn't give any rationale
for why that description
uh is in place and then in other
botanicals descriptions from the 1800s
like the the botanical description for
uh poa annua var reptans they talk about
it being present
year round right and for me one of the
the
the seminal papers that's detailed in
there uh is from the 60s where i think
it
was tim when took 6 000
different eco types from across europe i
think from portugal to finland
they plant all these at a central
location in germany
and only 40 of those 6
000 were true annuals the rest were
perennials
and there's a weak association between
you know
upright growth and seed head production
uh
and the ones that were annual but the
vast majority of these survived as
perennials yet over time
we've come to differentiate between
perennial and annual based on growth
habit and there's really not a whole lot
of data
to support that and i'm sure you and
carl see this in new york right
you know you showed poa from greens at
bethpage right and that would meet our
definition
of perennial type well i'm fairly
certain
you could go into the rough sit beth
page and you can find
upright growing poa annual with seed
heads
that's there 12 months a year so why is
that
annual and the green the poe on the
green is perennial you know one of the
things that we're
starting to believe is maybe this
species was misnamed
maybe it's all perennial and it
manifests itself as having an
annual life cycle in certain
environments and there are other
environments that help it to be
a continuing perennial over time okay
two things one is i'm assuming this is
part of the big usda grant you guys all
got across the country to
to uh investigate this on a deeper level
so let's start with
uh you know did we all did you guys all
come together this is one of the first
fruits of the beginning of that labor no
actually it's not
the focus of that usda grant is on
resistance management
in poe anu and the evolution of
herbicide resistance which is really a
transition zone
southern u.s thing um there are some
cases as you move
north but it's it's far more
concentrated in my region
this actually came out of
superintendents in the transition zone
reaching out
in say mid mid august with
multi-tiller poa in fairways
and asking what do i do you know i was
getting ready to start a traditional
pre-emergence program
these plants are here they must have
survived the summer we're not sure why
that kind of aligned with um devin's
start time of a phd program and as we
started to kind of peel back the layers
of the onion on this realize there's
there's a lot here to understand and
i kind of think that's why this is the
most interesting plant in turf right
yeah well i mean the more you stutter it
the more you find out you don't know
that well that's right and i would say
that a lot of my thinking early on was
shaped by the things
mary lush uh vic youngner and
and jabo found and then danny berger
sort of supported right
carl did some genetic stuff where he was
looking at the types of
uh flow rates or gene flows that he was
getting between the populations back i
think it was
carl's old could have been the 80s so
you know
my thinking was around well you know
in the rough where you don't water as
much
and drought stress is more the
environment as you say in the paper
where the environment's not conducive it
produces a lot of flowers looks really
straggly
gets really crab grass-like growth
and then dies and then you know when the
water returns or whatever
it regrows in places where the
irrigation is more uniform
where the drought stress doesn't hit
where the nutrients are applied more
uniformly
it behaves it behaves quote unquote like
a perennial
that's the stick i've had for 30 years
i guess i i want to know if we've
abandoned that completely
i don't know that we can see we
abandoned it frank because we don't know
yet but i think
at least from the point that we're at
now
i think it's an open question um
you know you think about environmental
management as you noted is going to
affect
morphology right and we've made all of
our distinctions about what
what is the life cycle of this grass
based on its morphological
characteristics
rather than actually monitoring length
of life
right and morphology is going to be
influenced by environment as you've
noted
and i think this is something for us to
better understand you know i mean i've
heard jill vargas give talks uh
you know about do you think that it's
it's cooler in the fairway than it is on
the green and that's why the the poe on
the green lives and the poe in the
fairway dies you know and
as comical as he can be i mean i think
he's got on a really good point that
there's probably a matrix of
let's call it killing conditions that
can make this plant not be
a perennial and then if you don't
satisfy that matrix it can live
for a longer amount of time and that's
what we're trying to understand more
because
what we see in the transition zone
particularly in warm season grass
is yeah we have a lot of resistance
problems
but we also have situations where poe
survives the summer here
and it's not it's not at scale right but
you think about if you're you know
you're going to go with a traditional
pre-emergence program particularly
around say bent grass putting greens
in bermuda grass well if i have poa
that that is presenting itself say like
poe trivialis
in that when it gets really hot it's
going to die back maybe to that crown
and be beneath that bermuda grass canopy
well it's probably not going to be
affected by a prediamine application of
residual chemistry
because it's already there it's mature
and it's rooted into the soil
those are the sorts of things that we're
trying to help superintendents with as
they struggle
particularly in those greens complex
situations to manage this
well listen it follows then when you say
environment it reminds me of uh i think
it was what i think of the man of la
mancha there was in it there was a guy
at penn state who looked at this with
dave huff and i don't know if you were
even
there back then i don't even recall how
long ago it was but it was the early
days of learning about
the impact of mowing on um
on on reproductive rate on fecundity uh
on flowering right how it would change
the way you mowed it
if you stopped mowing it it reverted and
and i what i want to get into is this
concept that i thought huff presented
where he said
yeah it's the mowing and it goes all the
way back to like the sterile hybrid
that is quote unquote oakmont poe that
produces no flowers at all
where does what you guys have found fit
into the huff thinking about
the impact of mowing as an environmental
stress
that's leading to it being almost
sterile
right so john lamanti and i we were
actually office mates
at penn state at the time and he's a
good friend and his work
was interesting then and is interesting
now uh
you know i think the stuff that they're
doing with mowing and poa is really cool
i do think it's a little bit tricky
because if you if you
dig into those papers what they're
really looking at
is the effect of mowing on dwarf
morphology
right and how that dwarf morphology is
maintained
over time but that is being presented in
our industry as
perenniality and the effect of mowing on
perenniality
which is not what they're doing right if
you look at
everything that john did at penn state
they never looked at length of life
at all they don't carry plants forward
to mortality
they looked at growth habit and seed
production and how mowing was affecting
those morphological parameters
and that's super interesting and super
cool work
but it doesn't relate to life cycle
but we but we confused it by cycling on
because then it leads into
seed head suppression and throat nose
control
uh the stress that you go on and the
amount of fungicides guys will use to
keep things
uh you know alive and going through the
year how does
that thinking of not knowing the life
cycle
altered begin to change the way you
think about the way we
manage well i think it kind of depends
on where in the country you
are right you know i mean one of the
things that i tell superintendents a lot
is you know
mother nature tries to tell you things
um you know if
you've got a lot of poa in your greens
why are we gonna try to fight that
uphill battle
maybe you know i learned this with this
patriot season maybe it's time to punt
and kind of like read the tea leaves and
uh
and uh you know kind of go with what
mother nature's telling you
and so i'm curious for me
it seems that we still talk about annual
perennial intermediate types you know
the annuals
you know sort of die from environmental
stress
and the perennials die from pest uh
problems diseases or annual bluegrass
weevil the annuals have
greater juvenile uh performance
but not good as adults and and
perennials
perform poorly as juveniles but do well
as adults
how does that model fit with what you
guys have
begun to uncover now yeah i mean i kind
of think one of the
the the approaches that we're working
through
and it's but not finished you know devin
is is only about halfway through her phd
work right now
is that we're working under an
assumption well what if it's all
perennial
and environment is what's manifesting
this as
annual versus perennial you look at mary
lush's work
right that talks about seed production
and overlapping secessions of seed
production
and in some climates that's going to
lead to
you're going to have poe present all
year and then other it's it's not you
can have a perennial plant that produces
seed and it's still perennial
rye grass is a perennial plant that
produces a lot of seed and it's still
perennial
but if i come into tennessee or georgia
and i oversee prairie rye grass it's
still going to be perennial and the
environment is going to make it present
itself as an annual
and we're wondering is the same true
with poem when you look at the genus
a large number of the species within the
genus poa are perennials
has this been a mischaracterized species
that it too
is perennial and when we have the wrong
environment for it
it will manifest itself as an annual
so how do you reconcile the concept of
the
supina trivialis
fusing uh hybridization idea from years
ago
so i mean we haven't dug into that and
because that's that's a little bit out
of my
skill set as a researcher an area of
expertise
i mean i think that all of that from my
knowledge of the literature could be
on point about how we got to this place
um but for us from a management
standpoint we still think with
you go back through the literature there
is not a lot of hard evidence to talk
about this being an
annual species okay so
um i'm gonna ask one more question and
then carl we'll see if there's any
questions from the audience but the
common way
of producing really good annual
bluegrass greens
uh from the scra from scratch is you
know the the
rabbidoo wingfoot model uh you know get
your cores
spread them out on some sand produce
a variety at your place uh put it on
sand and
you know put it under a lot of traffic
it's so it's a you know a lot of the
power golf courses up here in the
northeast gym or
are golf factories and that's of course
been exacerbated
uh this past year with kovid um
do you think there's any hope to
actually getting
improvements in poe that we could
move around more effectively because if
you you know
there are people selling oak monsant
it's working at beth page
is that the future for people who really
see poe annual as their species
i mean i'm not sure it's out of my
region but i definitely think it can be
an awesome putting surface if maintained
the right way
and i think environment plays a huge
role you know and we see this with other
annual you know i'm going to say weeds
because that's what i do for a living
you know you can put crabgrass in the
right tropical environment and it's
going to present itself as a perennial
turf cover right it's not going to die
off with that first heart frost
the same thing could be you know true
here with poa based on environment and
management and i think there'll be a
decision that has to be made you know is
the juice worth the squeeze
you know if i'm a superintendent in
tennessee or southern virginia
is it worth me trying to make a go of it
probably not
um but in your part of the world where
you and carl are in new york
well certainly that could be something
that um
could be a really good surface for you
moving forward and
the work that you i think the work that
you and carl are doing
looking at traffic patterns on greens
particularly poe greens as a function of
square footage
and rounds played i think that is
fascinating and it
is long overdue and explains a lot
of why there's critiques of this as a
surface
that's right okay carl how about some
questions because if there's not i got a
big one
for jim
i can't hear you we're we're all set on
questions so if you want to ask jim
something about
oh can you hear me okay so i got you
right now
right jim can you hear me i can hear you
all right good so
so um my question is something matt
elmore said when we had him on and i
know matt is near and dear to your heart
as a former grad student right yes and
we were talking about
crab grass and goose grass control uh
how goose grass is becoming obviously a
little bit more of an issue here in the
northeast
but also things like stiltgrass kailinga
and he made the comment about the a
growing number of weeds
figuring out how to out maneuver
pre-emergent controls
right that that weeds are evolving in
our lawn systems
uh to around our pre-emergent stuff and
i wonder if you couldn't comment on that
just philosophically
how you feel about that as what's
happening
in the weed world i know you think about
these things in a big way
from a resistance perspective but i'm
wondering if you think about it from an
ecological perspective
yeah i mean here i am thinking that your
big question for me was going to be
whether i had a mac jones jersey yet
come in with a scientific question all
right i better get ready
all right you know i i think that's
right i mean we've we've seen that
with species shifts here in tennessee
where you know
you take the clingus for example um when
i started in tennessee
we struggled to find sites to do kalinga
work
and now we struggle to find sites that
don't have kalinga in them
uh and we we we've seen
weed species shifts over time and i
think that'll continue and you know here
our emphasis has more been on weeds that
might have been say
gulf coast weeds that are now in the
northern transition zone
um you know doveweed's a good example of
that um purple nutsedge is another
you know when i started at tennessee in
2008 we didn't have purple nuts edge
on on our research farm and now we have
plenty to work with
um and i think that that's gonna
continue and we see it with all i mean
you have you have a weed scientist at
cornell who's working with palmer
amaranth in new york
right that's a mid-south uh cottonweed
and or crop system wheat i should say
and lynn cenos
he's working with it with all sorts of
different growers and different
commodities
you know in and around new york so i
mean i think it's one of the reasons why
weeds are
really fascinating to work with is that
ability to adapt to environment which
links back to what we're talking about
right
yeah it's the perfect full circle thing
and carl's got a bad connection jim so
i'll thank you on behalf of both of us
it's always great to see you uh you know
i was thinking jimmy g
you could be jimmy b right they're to
get jimmy g
back to new england or is it really
going to be a mac jones situation jim
it's so great to see you thanks for
taking the time and and give my best to
all our pals out there at
at tennessee and for carl scamenti i'm
frank rossi thanks for joining us on the
cornell turf show we'll be back uh next
week for week 10
uh and we'll look forward to seeing you
all then thanks a lot jim you take care
of yourself brother thanks guys thanks
for having me on
yeah happy to do it this has been a
production
of cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu